european leaders have agreed to sanction
belarus in response to its forced
diversion of orion air flight
and the arrest of a dissident journalist
now reacting to what they called
a hijacking member states decided to
take the following measures
belarusian airlines will be banned from
using
eu airspace and airports economic
sanctions and travel restrictions
will be imposed on a number of
individuals linked to the plane's
diversion
and a 3 billion euro eu investment
package for belarus
will remain on hold now according to the
eu commission president ozil founder
lyon
that will continue to be the case until
the country quote turns
democratic now the european council is
demanding
the immediate release of the detained
journalist rahman pratiz
his supporters fear for his safety
the 27 leaders of the european union do
not always find common ground
but their outrage was mutual over
belarus after the country intercepted a
passenger jet flying between eu states
and detained an exiled blogger and
activist on board
the judgment was unanimous this is an
attack
on democracy this is an attack on
freedom of expression
and this is an attack on european
sovereignty
ursula fonda line did not mince words as
she announced the eu's response to the
actions of belarus leader alexander
lukashenka
the european council decided that there
will be additional sanctions
on individuals that are involved
in the hijacking but this time also on
businesses
and economic entities that are financing
this regime the eu is also closing its
airspace to belarusian airlines and will
deny them access to eu airports
some european airlines like lufthansa
sas or klm announced
they would avoid belarusian airspace
this was triggered on sunday when exiled
activist rahman pratasiyevic was
arrested
traveling from greece to lithuania the
commercial flight he was on was grounded
by a belarusian warplane
because of an alleged bomb threat no
explosives were found on the aircraft
and
eu leaders are demanding answers
must be released immediately all the
explanations for the forced landing of
the ryanair flight are implausible
the same applies to his partner sophia
sapega we are demanding their release
a video appeared on a belarusian
pro-government telegram
channel with the imprisoned
prathasievich dark marks are visible on
his forehead
the opposition says prathasievich was
under pressure when he gave the
statement that he was treated according
to the law
in the past belarusian government had
already forced opposition leader
svetlana tianovskaya
to appear in a similar video while she
was in custody
we don't know what's happening to rahman
he could be interrogated by kgb
he may be tortured now as an enemy of
lukashenko
we are dealing with the harshest regime
in europe
in decades we will discuss migration
fund also announced that the eu put on
hold a three billion euro economic
package for belarus
until the country quote turns democratic
which will start at 10 o'clock
earlier i spoke to our brussels bureau
chief alexandre phelam and i asked her
if the
sanctions on belarus are as severe as
they could have been
no there were more options on the table
yesterday night for example friends
brought forward a proposal to suspend
all traffic including ground transit
from belarus to the european union
so that was also on the table however i
think it's fair to say that some member
states considered such a measure
too extreme and we have to keep in mind
what is the nature of the european
union's foreign policy making to have
a strong and also in united's response
you have to have all 27 members on board
and they often agree on measures then
all members
can agree on and i think in this case it
was very important for the eu leaders to
present an una united front
on belarus right that was our brussels
bureau chief
i'm now joined by journalist hannah
lubakova she is in minsk
good morning to you hannah so how is the
news of the eu sanctions
being received in belarus
well belarusians definitely want the
impunity to stop and they expected a
strong and consequent response very
tangible
practical steps from the eu from western
countries from the democratic world
so i would say that they did expect
sanctions
the sanctions list be expanded be
broadened by
by by the eu by the u.s and other
countries
when it comes to individual and targeted
smart economic sanctions
uh belarusians definitely want those
sanctions be well thought
be painful for the regime not for the
people
and it's really important to target
oligarchs it's really important to
target lugoshenko's finances
um and kind of the finances of his
cronies abroad so so that's kind of the
um common i would say well opinion here
uh
when it comes to banning flights over
belarus and kind of forbidding
borussians to to to come to europe
closing the borders i i would say that
here
we should be cautious because many
people flee the country and they
uh they are looking for a refuge in the
eu because the you know in fear of
prosecution
in belarus and another important issue
is that
uh they want the agenda of the new free
and fair presidential elections
uh come back uh on on kind of the eu
agenda
and uh so that the talks about the new
elections are resumed
hannah belarusian authorities have
released a video of
rahman pratiz uh as mentioned in our
report it was likely filmed
under duress and i'd like to tell of you
that that is the reason why we're not
going to be showing you that video but
hannah tell us
about that video
well i've known roman for years and it
was
horrible to see him in such a condition
he looks horrified
he looks very distressed his voice
trembles
he has marks over his face over his
forehead which
might mean that he might have been
bitten
then all of a sudden he says that he
doesn't have any health problems
uh he is being treated well and then he
um
kind of confesses that he took part in
uh plotting riots in belarus which is
punishable up to 15 years in prison
so it all kind of raises questions about
whether you know what what's happening
to him whether he has been tortured
whether he has been threatened um let's
remember that he is on the kgb
terrorist list so it might also kind of
scare him what might
happen to him and also his girlfriend
his travel companion is being detained
so she's also not safe at the moment
and it might also cause a lot of
distress on him
all right that's the journalist hannah
lubakova talking to us from minsk thank
you hannah
you